it says chicken burger on it it's
definitely vegetarian right this isn't a
prank
I like pandas are like high-end fast
food I guess burgers that still cost $10
every Shake Shack or chick-fil-a or
anything like that so I'm just kind of
like I just usually don't go in there
I'm like they won't come for me this
really does feel like that's true
fast-food this is good it's just kind of
weird I wouldn't write this but I keep
eating it so there's no time to talk
four out of five what aren't what are
the seven layers looks like four layers
you're fine you know this is like a
snack what do you call an appetizer I
definitely just drunk for sure what's
your rating 3.5 just a fool I would give
this one a two and a half out of five
but I still appreciate it
I mean its food all food is good that's
not true that's so good you're a foo-foo
is it a breakfast sandwich I love
breakfast I really hate that they always
market vegetarian
and why do you think we're doing it for
like healthy low cholesterol but like I
want the yellow part I like this but it
reminds me of aeroplane food like it
could have existed for 12 months on the
shelf before it's in your stomach but
you don't eat it I would say the bread
is a1 and the overall sandwich is the
point 5 the British people rubbish I
want to watch you take your first bite
[Music]
did I hype it up too much as anything
you like it no it's so good it's so
simple it doesn't even like me fake meat
it has a 5 yeah I think if you mix the
in-n-out burger with the burger patty oh
oh my god babe you have being a
vegetarian in America for eight years I
didn't know about all these things
besides this now that I know that exists
I'm probably gonna be
I'm gonna keep going in and out but
probably nowhere else tomorrow we'll
have something richer
notice don't you feel like talking to
the guy why you wearing lipstick
[Music]
[Music]